All right, let's give this a shot and see
how it goes.
I think this is going to key.
Interesting.
I told you at the start of last week that
I have been self censoring myself on some
topics, not because of monetization you reasons
on youtube, but because of an effort basically
to preserve my sanity.
I did a long segment last week explaining
that I've tended not to take on certain topics
because merely broaching the topics is me
choosing to deal with two weeks of nonsense
on my social media feeds and email inbox and
youtube channel.
Uh, and some of those topics include everything
from talking about the squad in anything but
the most glowing terms or talking about Venezuela
in anything but glowing terms or even mentioning
Tulsi Gabard or the Israeli Palestinian conflict
of some examples.
So today I'm going to talk about sort of the
Israeli conflict.
I'm going to specifically talk about a vote
that was taken in the United States related
to what is called the bds movement last week.
And, yeah, I mean, to some extent, I don't
know why I'm doing this, uh, but we will see
sort of what the reactions are.
I'm making an effort not to self-censor the
reactions to my segment last week where David,
we understand that we may disagree on some
issues, but don't self censor.
You will be surprised at actually how people
will respectfully engage you on the substance
rather than, uh, going down the Ad Hominem
antisemitic rabbit hole.
For example, if you talk about this bds vote.
So let's see.
Let's see how it goes.
Um, let's do it.
Uh, my, my only request is listen to what
I'm actually saying.
If your comment or your response is not based
on what I've said, then it's worthless and
I'm going to ignore it.
Okay.
Recently there was a vote in the House of
Representatives, HR two 46 easily passed with
both democratic and Republican support.
I believe it's 17 Democrats voted against
it, but numerous so-called progressive heroes
voted in favor of the bill, uh, to condemn
the boycott divestment sanctions movement
against Israel.
And this includes Ro Khanna, who I know a
little bit personally.
This includes Diana Presley from here in Boston.
This includes Tulsi Gabard, who voted in favor
of the bill to condemn bds, and it instantly
spun some elements of the progressive media
sphere into disarray.
We've been betrayed.
How dare these so called progressive's vote
in this way.
So let's break it down piece by piece.
And again, if you're going to respond with
anything that includes, for example, comments
about me being Jewish, that is not what I
would call a substantive response.
If you're going to respond with smears about
these elected officials who voted one way
or the other, that's not a productive conversation.
Let's actually talk about the substance.
Let's first start with the premise that I
imagine all democrats, uh, who are considered
themselves even remotely progressive.
So this includes people like Rocana and I,
Anna Presley, who voted for the bill and those
who voted against the bill.
I believe that we all share the goal of wanting
Israel to change its policy towards Palestinians.
I believe we're all United against the right
wing government of Benjamin Netanyahu, which
I've been talking about my opposition to for
years, and I think my progressive audience
is basically on board with, so then we get
to one element of this, which is the bds movement.
The bds movement dates back to 2005 again,
it's bds, boycott, boycott, divestment sanctions.
The idea is to force or shame Israel into,
I guess treating Palestinians better as they
see it by boycotting Israeli businesses.
This includes individuals participating in
boycotts.
This includes lobbying businesses and even
countries or city governments, local governments
to boycott Israel.
So let's charitably assume in good faith that
bds supporters truly believe that bds will
push the government to change in this respect.
My first disagreement with bds is that I disagree
that it will work.
It's a pragmatic disagreement.
The first bit of evidence is that it's been
around almost 15 years and it has accomplished
almost nothing.
Now, I know people will write to me and they'll
say, but David, there have been some localities
or some countries, I think Ireland had a vote
where they say we are not going to do business
with Israel.
Uh, and that's true.
There have been some academic departments
that have said we are going to boycott and
divest from Israel.
Many of them don't even have investments or
business with Israel to begin with.
The point is nothing has changed in terms
of policy or in the improving of the lives
of Palestinians as as result of the bds movement.
And it's actually stunning in fact, because
they've had a pretty significant PR impact.
I mean, again, entire country speaking in
favor of the movement and yet there is policy.
We all disagree with those of us who favor
bds and those of us who oppose it and none
of those policies have changed.
Now there is a big argument that takes place
around bds.
Is bds antisemitic?
And the answer is, here we go.
Now listen to what I'm going to say.
No.
BDS is not inherently antisemitic any more
than boycotting.
China is inherently anti Asian or boycotting.
Saudi Arabia is anti Saudi or anti Muslim
or anti Arab or whatever.
But bds does provide cover for lots of antisemites.
Again, importantly, without having achieved
anything of substance over the last 14 years,
bds as successes include convincing some artists
not to do concerts in Israel.
It's not doing much for the Palestinian people.
I want to do something for the Palestinian
people.
They've had colleges vote in favor of bds
proposals, the number of which has been declining
over the years.
That's starting to fade.
And meanwhile from other places, there are
record investments in Israel.
New Jersey divested from a bank that participates
in bds, Ohio made record investments in Israeli
bonds, intelligence scaled up Israeli investment.
Dozens of examples.
So listen, I get it.
This is a tactic that might work.
I don't believe it has worked and I think
that we need to go in a different direction
now.
There's another problem which is that it's
very overtly and Al boycott Israel when it's
convenient movement, but not other countries
because it's inconvenient.
And as soon as it's not convenient to boycott
Israel, I won't boycott Israel anymore.
So let's go through it.
What about China?
Right?
China's human rights abuses are horrible.
Who's boycotting China?
Well, very few people because we need those
Chinese products.
Whether it's your iPhone, whether it's other
electronics, whether it's clothing, whatever
the case may be, it's simply not practical.
They say to boycott China, boycott Israel
is much more practical until of course you
need the emergency bandage that was used to
save the life of Gabby Giffords when she was
shot.
Or we still for boycotting that and using
a subpar product to save a life.
I don't think so.
Boycott Israel until a family member needs
a medical treatment or humanitarian efforts,
need Israeli products boycott Israel until
uh, a family member has multiple sclerosis,
in which case most people will say, yeah,
let's just use the good drug, which is the
one developed by the Weitzman Institute and
sold by Teva pharmaceuticals from Israel.
So let me be really clear about why I'm mentioning
this.
I don't want people to forego what is the
best treatment because they want to boycott
Israel.
What I'm pointing out is then it's soon as
it's inconvenient.
The boycott falls.
Do you shop at trader Joe's?
Last time I was there.
Terrific.
Israeli fed a cheese at trader Joe's imported
as well as other Israeli products.
Are you supporting there but saying that you
support bds cause there's an inconsistency.
Do you shop at whole foods?
Whole foods has actually made a statement
where they said we do not boycott Israeli
products at whole foods.
Well maybe you go to stop and shop if you
live in the northeast of the United States.
Wait a second.
Stop and shop is one of the biggest Israeli
product selections around Passover, including
those really great chocolate covered marshmallows.
So are you actually boycotting, are you sort
of repeating the talking point without understanding
what's going on?
So the problem with bds is that it is as ineffective
as it is capricious in its application.
Okay.
You won't buy a soda stream to make your own
seltzer, but when the rubber hits the road,
most people will abandon their principles
as soon as it's necessary or convenient just
to go and do the grocery shopping.
So in the end, bds asserts nothing that will
promote peace.
It is simply failed and it divides the left
groups that would be very glad to work together.
Like for example, Jewish groups that are for
Palestinian rights, for getting rid of the
Netanyahu administration for stopping the
settlements but aren't in favor of bds, would
be able to be working with so many of these
other groups if bds was not driving this wedge
between them.
So then we get to this vote on HR two 46.
Uh, there are people who thought Rocana was
great as an example, California congressman,
until he voted in favor of the bill and now
they are insulting him or saying, well, the
reason why Rowe Kinda did this is because
he supports Bernie and Bernie's Jewish and
clearly Bernie, uh, hypnotized Rocana into
voting for the bill.
Maybe Rocana just assessed the circumstances
and decided it made sense to vote for the
bill.
Oh, David, you're against the, you're, you're
for the bill.
You're against it.
Whatever your position is informed by being
Jewish.
Maybe.
I just think that this is really a distraction
of a bill and that bds is a wedge that is
going to get in the way of us advancing our
a shared goal of improving circumstances for
Palestinians and Israeli Palestinian peace.
What would unite the left would be to say
at its basic principles, we need a president
here in the United States who is not going
to give divisive gifts to Israel like moving
the embassy to Jerusalem.
We need to recognize that the left is in agreement
on 95% of this issue.
I simply disagree that bds will work or that
it will unite any important coalitions in
order to achieve the change that we all want
and sadly it does also function as a veil
for some antisemitism.
For some people.
That's my view on this issue.
I'm ready for the criticisms, make them substantive.
I'm going to ignore you if it's about me being
a Zionist shell or whatever else that that's
not serious conversation.
I'm looking to actually explain to you why
I think this is a movement that has already
failed and that there are ways in which we
can work together rather than arguing about
bds to improve the lives of Palestinians
and Israeli Arabs and quite frankly of Jews
around the world as well who don't benefit
from the continuation of the status quo.
Let me know what you think